[Music]
so on our
Crest you have a pattern
and throughout the pattern you have a
understanding of East Asian martial arts
but it's it's not really anything that
esoteric okay
it has to do that there
are these directions whoops
whatever
um so you have one two 3 four five 6 7 8
you have eight
directions the cardinal directions and
the diagonals and these kind of
represent that those are all the
directions that that you have okay this
is why you have like
shidi but you also have haidi so shidi
is the four cardinal directions like you
have north
south okay West
East
okay and obviously
Northwest what is this northeast
East am I doing this right yeah
Southeast
Southwest
okay but you also have hooi hoo means
eight directions so you do that you add
the diagonals in okay um it's the same
in knife fighting you have angles one
angle two all that kind of stuff that's
in there um we have ski so you also have
to understand that there is a
verticality to this that's going this
way and so if you look at Ed Parker's
work he'll take that two-dimensional
diagram that we have on our Crest and
they'll blow it out to a
three-dimensional diagram and you can
see what these eight directions look
like in a sphere okay and so there's it
goes out this way too and so that's how
you have ski and you have showen and you
have Yoko men and those represent in
those three all the possible directions
that something can go in okay um so as
as you have yoka man you can always
reverse it just like you would in in
knife so I have this slash well I have
that slash you have yo man here and you
have your outward hand sword too okay
inward hand sword outward hand sword and
that would give you the other
angle
um in our
Kona the Kona uh curriculum
them your techniques most of them nearly
all of them will concentrate on these
angles okay so this one over
here this one over here this one over
here this one over
here and this is because these angles
are uh mechanically connected to
mid-range
grappling um this north south angle or
this right angle here it's very
difficult to move uh the body from the
area of the elbows to the wrist and
using these these angles the cardinal
directions and the reason why is because
you're going to contest that's what's
going to
happen in close range grappling that
that is where you start to see the
cardinal directions okay so in iido Kaza
if we're doing like kagia and we're
clearly at that elbow wrist range of
mid-range grappling obviously we throw
at the corners in koshinaga we're at
close range grappling and that's where
you work on the north south kind of
stuff okay you get underneath it it goes
over the top of you Etc okay
um therefore inversely if we're doing a
mid-range grappling technique uh we want
to stay away from this north south and
the East West because you're going to
contest okay if we're doing like uh
koshinaga double leg single leg any of
those kind of things uh katuma that's
where you start working on those 90°
because the guy is actually going over
you that's how you don't cont test okay
uh why does he have to go over you cuz I
can't get to the side do you see if I
can get to the side then I get these
other angles okay if I'm on the side and
I try to make him go vertical you're
going to get too much mass you're going
to contest you won't have your
mechanical advantage so let me kind of
demonstrate what that means okay
okay so if I'm going to do for example
cou nuggin and I had to have gotten to
the angle do you see and then I can
throw him at those
Corners this
one that
one make
sense if I get to the side and I try to
spin
him this
way things get heavy heavier okay does
that make sense
likewise if I can't get off to the side
and I'm here and I try to throw him
things get
heavier so if we're here here's where
you can
get things get light again okay all
right C you
hole is is
midrange it's not going to be close
range I and also I got off to the side I
got off the line so I don't want to use
the cardinal
direction
down
up he should not go
down I don't make his head go
down they bring it up and then
down so you could
see if he gets to the side and he goes
and he brings me down okay I'm down my
head went down and we're never going to
get back up never going to get back
up
okay your UK though in nikito will do it
for you your UK always
goes down I don't
think okay but no one does that in real
life you guys might have experienced
this in G was that when you bring you're
like you're going to take the guy down
right you go like down and then you
always try to go up and they're just
sitting there so he goes he goes down
and then like here and he tries to go up
and like no we're not going up cuz you
took me down okay
so this his head needs to come at the
angle not
down not down St there and then I round
vertical I'm not going like he goes
down and then I round
vertical I'm not going down
and then I round
vertical that's not it that would only
work if he does that for me okay I have
to bring his head this
[Music]
way so his head doesn't go
down his head goes this way
so that o that o Yin yield has to happen
on the angles not on the north south
cardinal direction does that make sense
okay so I don't need
to
lower
then my hand is here
and when I bring it in that was all I
had to do don't I don't have to lower it
I just bring it
[Music]
in that's
it that is
it so here's our
drill one
if I do this correctly when I go up
he'll go backwards because you're doing
this to his
head his head is going
here his inertia keeps going
forward and then I went
up and it makes his head go backward you
guys see that okay so that will be our
drill boom boom if you lose your balance
and you fall take you cany but you might
not it doesn't matter but I don't make
my arm go
backward and make it go up okay all
right let's try let's get into that a
little more that's what's going on
though but okay how do you get there um
well you only have two spirals okay so
this start even though I'm turning this
way this is my outward spiral because
the hand goes that way okay so I have my
out spiral I have my kator elbow angle
and I keep that angle I keep that angle
War okay now I'm going to do the inward
spiral so I come
up and I do the inward
[Music]
spiral don't violate the rules that that
is nothing that's not one thing okay
this isn't anything either
here that's it second thing this is a
head pass just like on
ten I start with his grip and I'm going
to pass his head to my arm boom that's
what I'm
doing and then from there I control his
head
so this is our arm
pass from the wrist this time on the
outside upper arm tensi is inside lower
arm KY hole outside upper arm so I'm
going to pass his head right
here right here okay that's where where
it is now his grips irrelevant and I
just do my
movement third
thing I have to use I key which means I
have to match the Yang value if I
overwrite it I'll
slip when I go up I slip past him if I'm
under it he'll go flying by me okay so
you have to match the energy that he has
at his face boom W and then you'll get
it okay makes sense okay let's try those
three things
try so uh
all I need for the throw to happen to
ever happen is that that's all I need
for any mid-range grappling throw that's
it okay you never
need
that
okay so if you're if you get here what
tends to happen is you get here and
you're going to move your elbow back
that way
to get him to start going backwards you
see and you don't want
that the arm's not the throat the arm is
the Tilt the arm is the Tilt cuz here's
where my leg comes in do you understand
and now it's realistic okay if I get a
little tilt and all I'm trying to do
with the arm is get energy that was
going forward to going backwards that's
all I need and then p and you're in okay
so here's here would be his spine it
tilts this
way legs go forward Center goes forward
that makes the head go back before he
walks here he's never going to walk
there
okay he's coming in he tilts Center
keeps going forward he starts going
backwards I'm in okay
and as I'm
in
Boom the legs start to come up the head
starts to go down you see and that's
where my arm now takes it's going to
take that
inertia and guide it
around this way so it's falling and I'm
going like that now there's no way he
can get his legs back underneath him
okay does that make sense I'm never
bending this in half and pushing it
straight down I think that a lot of
people don't do this first part
sometimes out of ignorance you're
working on the vertical plane and you
don't want to work on the vertical
plane sometimes out of culture UK is
going to fix it for you okay but
sometimes they do it when they don't
realize that throws have to be
incremental
mentally uh built you can't you're never
going to have like you got them okay
it's not like that they're all
incrementally built meaning one thing
only does a little tiny thing and then
another thing does another little tiny
thing do you see when one thing has to
do a whole lot of it's not
practical it's never going to happen
Okay
so I don't need this arm
to make his head go backwards I just
need this arm to make his inertia go
backwards and to tilt him at the
beginning so tilt him in and have his
inertia go back that was it after that
it stops the legs come in and now as
he's falling this arm comes around and
brings his head over here okay does that
make sense so I think as you're going
that's where this temptation comes from
you shove them back like
that don't need that you just get his
inertia going in your
in that's all you're doing so if you
paid attention I left my hand up and his
head he went that way he didn't go this
way you think okay does that make sense
so I'm going to leave my hands up and
come in more going on that
way that way once I bring my hand in
once he gets
light goes that way
you see okay okay
um it's important to
note that my
arm is never going
and making him go that
way nor does my
arm make him go
down so my arm is never working okay
there's nothing in my
arm
um let's
see as as we're here the inertia is
making him go that way so disarm didn't
do any of
that and then when he's here like
this this base coming in is what's
lowering his
head so the arm does not do that does
that make sense the arm guides a
fallowing body around
okay um so make sure you're not using
your arm to do any of this pushing of
any kind the arm doesn't do anything
okay um anything any other last
points and I'm not
covering just on that
part yes so since say this is this seems
to be a perfect example of what you talk
about aiming a falling body yes aiming a
falling body the body's already falling
okay don't don't don't try to knock it
down okay with your arm that doesn't
make sense okay
um all right let's work on that